à l'Éternel jeunesse de la femme que
j'aime 25 ans de boîte tu demandes un
truc à l'amour de ma vie écoute va
chercher le gâteau quand on finit
sensation de chaleur aucune vous avez
pris un petit peu de poids donc c'est
génial vous n'avez aucun symptôme de la
ménopause
[Musique]
je te dis qu'elle a pas d'amour arrête
avec ça ton amant c'est Stéphane point
d'interrogation c'est qu'il y a un doute
vraiment je ne suis pas avec cet homme
c'était un jeu tu es amoureuse de moi
ça fait 30 ans qu'on est ensemble on est
pas des amoureux c'est pas
on est un couple
c'est pas quoi moi je t'aime alors
il faut qu'on se manque qu'on ait peur
de se perdre c'est dangereux
tu dois faire un papier dessus célibat
50 ans nouveau départ on va de garage
ça plaît pas tu jettes
[Musique]
tu crois
ah non l'artiste le beau gosse pas de
ventre tous ses cheveux
pour manger
maman c'est ta vie tu as décidé de
prendre en main et on s'en fout que
machine elle est 35 ans
[Musique]
et tu rentres chez toi
désolé je n'ai pas compris votre demande